Hello everybody!
Alright, so we have a little problem.
I don't know how to fix this.
I've been trying to fix it for 10 minutes, but I can hear myself in the game!
Yes, good morning, because I literally woke up 30 minutes ago from a stress nap.
Because, you know, whenever you feel like, oh my god, there's so much stuff to do.
And then you're like, what if I nap away my problems?
Yes, do you hear the voices right now?
Do you hear... do you hear... do you hear two of me right now?
I don't know.
I don't know if you hear it right now, but like, if you don't hear it now, don't worry.
You'll hear it now.
I don't...
Okay, alright.
I... I don't know!
I don't know!
I've been trying to fix it for 20 minutes!
I can't... I can't fix it!
Like, I nap myself, but I don't want to hear more than two of me, because it's so hard to talk.
I don't know if you guys know this, but, like, when you hear a feedback of your own voice...
Um, and it's like a little bit delay.
It's actually really hard to talk because it, like, fucks you up.
Like, if there's like a small... no, it's because I tabbed out!
It's only fixed when I'm not tabbed into the game So like if I do this, I can hear myself now.
I have to talk slower because hearing myself fucks with my brain.
So I have to talk slower.
Fix it!
Okay, I'm gonna turn off the output right now.
So I don't... oh my... okay.
Okay, I'm gonna... actually, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm gonna turn off the output right now.
Alright, so you don't hear me.
But I hear me.
Okay, I'm gonna mute myself too.
Okay, so like, the thing is...
I don't know what to... I checked my settings.
Yeah?
So like, I was looking through it.
It's not this.
It's not... I even like...
I even like...
Made sure to like, you know... I don't wanna hear master... hear master volume.
I turned that off.
It didn't work.
And then like, I turned all of these off.
It didn't work either.
I'm so conf... oh my god.
Okay, I'm like flashing in and out right now.
I'm gonna put borderless.
Like it's... I shouldn't, but like I'm like flashing.
I'm like, I see myself too.
Not only do I hear myself, but I also see myself.
I should...
You guys don't hear anything right now.
But I do.
It's not an OBS thing.
It's act... it's like... it's like... it's related to the game.
But like, I... I don't know... what can... what can fix it?
I don't know.
I'm so confused.
Like...
It's not audio voice chat!
Okay, I'm gonna...
Alright.
It's not... Oh, wait.
Okay, nevermind.
I hear myself.
Wait.
Wait, no.
I hear myself.
Yeah, I forgot.
I muted the thing.
Okay, I'm gonna turn all of this off.
Okay.
Yeah.
It doesn't work.
But what if...
What if... No.
No.
Okay.
Does anyone remember what it was?
Does anyone... Does anyone remember...
Was this three...
I don't remember...
Okay, I'm gonna turn off...
I turn off the...
My mic on OBS.
Wait.
That helps you guys, but it doesn't help me!
Because I have to hear myself!
Okay, nevermind.
Because like... Because like... I...
I have to listen to myself!
Like...
Okay.
Alright.
What else can we do, guys?
What else?
Guys!
What was these?
I don't remember!
Oh, I'm just gonna...
Reset settings...
Does it reset all my other stuff?
Nooooooo...
It's... Steam mic settings...
Steam setting... Voice... Push to talk...
Where's Steam mic?
Where the fuck is that?
Sorry, I'm... I'm not stupid...
Because I'm talking slow...
It's because... It's very difficult...
To talk...
Okay... Okay...
Uh... Shift... Tab... Settings... Voice...
Oh!
Push to talk!
Did it work?
Hello?
Nope.
Okay...
Uuuuuuuuuhhhh...
Uuuuuuuuuuuhhhh...
Uuuuuuuuhhhh...
Nooo... Noooo...
Okay...
Did it work?
No...
No, it didn't...
Okay... Push to talk... Push to talk...
And then... Reset.
Okay... Okay...
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Oh my god, please.
Okay, I'm gonna restart my game.
Alright guys.
Alright, I'm res- Sorry, that was so trippy.
That was so trippy.
Yes, welcome to Bodycam.
The game.
Woah!
Holy shit.
Guys.
How?
Why is it so loud?
It's not stopping!
Oh my god.
Oh.
What the fuck?
Okay.
Okay, I don't hear myself anymore.
Good news.
I'm so sorry.
I booted it up.
And then...
I booted it up and it played a YouTube video.
But like, I couldn't mute it.
Like, it was so fucked up.
But!
Good news is...
I don't hear myself anymore.
So...
That's good news.
Hey guys!
I don't hear myself anymore.
Okay, but you guys...
Okay.
Alright.
We fixed it.
Everything's good now.
Alright.
Anyway.
Oh wait, I'm not showing it.
Okay, give me a sec.
Alright.
Good news is...
Good news is... the double... I just had to...
Uh, like the old thing.
Have you ever tried turning it on and off again?
That was the key.
We just had to turn it on and off again.
We had to go a little bit deaf for...
I'm so sorry.
I don't know.
It was like this video.
And like, if I press play, it's gonna play like a really loud video.
And...
This was the issue all along.
This...
This was it.
So, yay!
We fucking did it!
I'm gonna put it back to full screen.
I feel like full screen is the best for me.
Okay.
Oh, this reset itself too.
Okay, so I'm gonna...
I'll put that here.
And then...
And then I think...
I think that's good.
Alright.
Wait, why is it like that?
Why is it like this?
Guys, what is wrong with this game?
Okay, sorry.
Alright, it like...
I couldn't click on anything for a bit.
Okay, anyway.
For those who don't know what this...
This game has like 2000 reviews, I feel like.
Um, wait.
No, it had more.
Okay.
So, for those who don't know what this game is...
This is... Oh my god, it's like flashing in and out.
Sorry.
I was like...
My...
My face is like flashing through the game.
Oh my god.
Alright.
Sorry.
So, for those who don't know what this game is...
This is basically like a very realistic shooter.
It's like apparently one of the most realistic shooters out there.
It's not Unrecord.
These guys capitalized on Unrecord.
Unrecord was the original...
Um...
It was the original body cam shooter game.
That went viral.
This one is...
Two guys that saw...
Unrecord...
Go viral...
And then made the game first.
And released the game first.
So...
They saw...
They saw Unrecord...
And then they released this first.
Before Unrecord could release.
Um... But...
I heard that like...
People said like...
This game looks crazy.
But like... If you have a shitty PC...
You cannot run it.
Because you know...
The graphics for this is insane.
In terms of like...
Quote on quote...
Realism.
I don't know.
I try to make it so that...
I try to make it less realistic.
Because I heard the...
I heard the...
The homelessness for this...
Is like...
Pretty insane.
So like...
I am sorry if like...
It still...
Uh...
Oh yeah...
Apparently, it's a bit poorly optimized.
Apparently, the optimization for this...
Is a little iffy.
Um...
Anyway.
Anyway...
Okay, not a little bit.
But it could be pretty bad, the optimization, because of the whole realism part.
What else do I have to say?
Yeah.
I tried to lessen the camera shake.
You can lessen the camera shake.
So we'll see how this goes.
We'll see...
We'll see what it's like to play this game.
Alright, start match.
Do I... I'll do a quick play.
Automatic buy and join the closest or fullest server.
Alright, you know what?
Does anyone else have this game?
Okay, I'll do a quick play first.
I feel like I'll get absolutely destroyed.
But we'll do a quick play first.
Alright, blood indicates... Okay, cam connected.
Whoa!
I knew I forgot to do something.
I did everything but my sensitivity.
Okay, let me fix that.
Alright.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh look.
Marked.
Marky boy, what are you doing over here, Marky boy?
Whoa.
What are you trying to do?
Alright, FBI open up right now.
Whoa, the drone's coming.
Wait, how do I fly?
How do I...
Whoa.
Yo, okay.
I can tell where the motion sickness is coming in now.
Oh shit.
What the fuck?
Oh!
Poor guy.
Okay.
Alright.
Where's my gun?
That's my gun.
Okay.
Oh.
Oh my god.
It's like I'm actually walking.
Oh.
Do I just...
Are we trying to disarm something?
Where are the...
Imagine this in VR.
I know.
This is actually crazy if this was in VR.
This is actually...
This feels so wonky.
Oh my god.
It feels so fucking wonky.
Not gonna lie.
Oh!
It's so loud!
Oh my god.
It's so loud.
The shooting is so...
Okay.
The volume was like guys don't you know guns are real and guns are very loud.
Oh no.
My teammates are dead.
How is that possible?
I'm sorry.
I didn't realize.
Where are they?
What?
I'm so...
I'm making this so bad.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I don't know.
I was like whoa.
I was still...
Holy shit guys.
I can't believe it.
People die so fast.
Cause like it's real.
It's so real.
Wait.
Am I the only one here?
All my teammates left me.
I'm sorry.
Is it cause I'm open micing?
I can't tell.
I'm sorry.
My teammates left me.
Oh no.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for being bad.
I literally just got...
It's okay.
I don't...
I'm just playing.
I just started playing.
No.
How was I supposed to know?
I'm supposed to know!
What?
Stop it!
Oh my god, I have teammates!
Oh thank god!
Cheesekeep and Richard Scale!
Okay.
Okay, alright.
Jesus Christ.
Probably should go- the word cannot go!
I feel like there's like one way!
Guys, did you guys know that like, how do I climb?
How do I climb in this realism?
Guys, I don't know if I can climb.
Okay.
Is there another route?
Okay, don't go there.
Okay, we'll go this way.
I wanna go to the forest!
The forest was- did you guys- the forest map was the most interesting one.
For me.
Alright.
When can I be defense?
I feel like defense is the cooler way to play.
Defense you can actually camp.
Okay.
Guys, do you see them?
I feel like they're gonna see me before I see them.
Where are they?
Oh, there's Chief Skeef.
There he is!
There's Chief Skeef!
Where are they?
Ugh!
Did we do it?
We did it!
Hahahaha!
Weeeeee!
We did it!
I'm still learning!
But we did it!
Holy shooot!
Hahahaha!
Guys, yes, I did it!
I did do something!
I found another staircase to go up!
What do you mean I did nothing?
I found a second staircase!
Where are they?
This is so scary.
Because it's so real.
So I don't know where they are.
Hello?
Hey guys.
Where are they?
Where the bum?
We did it!
Yeah!
I did nothing!
Hahahaha!
How's the volume so far?
Yeeey!
Hahahaha!
That's fucking right!
I have a full team now!
I have Chief Ski!
Hahahaha!
That you?
That's right!
Goodbye!
Okay.
Wow, guns are loud.
Did you guys know that?
Guns are fucking loud.
Hahahaha!
Wow!
No!
What the fuck?
Who killed me?
Who the fuck killed me?
Hehehehehe!
Woah!
Round lost?
We have four people!
How could the round...
Wait, I didn't kill that man?
I'm sad.
I didn't kill him.
Okay, let's turn down the volume a little bit.
There you go.
Jesus Christ.
Bring me to the forest!
The forest is where all the cool kids are!
Guns, guns, guns!
Oh, bam!
What do you mean?
Aren't you excited?
It's a shooter!
Hahahaha!
You get to be an FBI?
Or a SWAT team?
I don't know.
It's just... it's like a tactical shooter.
But it's real.
It's for real.
Wait, he's dead.
Now he's extra dead.
I contributed.
Wait, it's... okay.
We did it.
Guys!
I can help!
AHHHHHHHHHH!
What if I just shoot him right now?
What if I...
Is he doing it?
Did he do it?
Did he just chuck it?
Hahahaha!
We won!
It doesn't matter!
Did we?
Yeah, we did.
Okay.
I didn't get penalized for it too.
That's great.
Guys, bring me to the forest!
The forest seems like the most fun map!
Alright, after this game, we're gonna host our own map.
And do the forest.
That's all I wanted to do.
The forest.
I wanna do defense too.
It feels like defense has the most fun as well.
Okay, I'm gonna rush in.
They won't expect it because I can barely hear anything too.
Wait, where are they?
Wait, what?
Where are they?
Hello?
Wait, where's the bomb?
The bomb is like here.
Where did he place the bomb?
Hello?
It's clearly beeping somewhere.
I don't know where the bomb is either!
I'm stuck!
They placed it below us?
Holy shit!
The wild man!
He actually placed it below us!
It's off the volume now.
That's actually fucking crazy!
You can do that?
Wait, I'm gonna go back.
I see it.
Please!
No!
Was I close?
Guys, was I close?
Do you think I was close?
Guys!
Guys, do you think I was close?
Do you think I almost did it?
Guys, I'm an apex player, not a Valorant player.
Please!
It's right here!
It's below us!
Oh, whoops!
Sorry, I'm not very good at driving drones as well.
Do we do it?
Oh, guys, I don't think we did it, guys.
I don't think we did it.
How are we losing?
It's a fucking 4v2!
We can't be that bad!
Oh, it's a 4v3 now.
Okay.
No, it's nighttime?
Oh, no.
That's worse.
How do I see at night?
Oh, we have a flashlight.
Oh, I'm defending.
Oh.
I was like, wait, what am I holding?
Whoops.
Guys, my camera's gonna drown now.
Guys, I didn't realize we were defending.
I think
the teammate was mad at me.
I'm pretty shit.
I'm pretty... Wait, you can shoot through that?
Holy shit.
How was I supposed to know we were defending?
I was too busy trying to figure out what I'm doing.
Okay.
Please.
No, I don't wanna hold on to... Why am I holding on to this?
I don't know.
We'll put it on the staircase.
I don't know how to put down... They just kill me because they don't know.
They know I don't know how...
They kill me because they know I don't... I was like...
How do
I...
The RIT was so mean to me.
I'm so fucked up, man.
I can't believe it.
They killed me because they don't know how to put down the bomb.
I didn't even want the bomb in the first place.
I didn't know I was gonna pick up the bomb.
There's my... I contributed, guys.
Guys.
Oh, the enemy killed me.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
At least I know...
At least I know I contributed, guys.
We did it.
We won the round.
Please.
Oh, thank God.
Oh, thank...
Yay!
Wait.
How do I see through the night?
Wait a minute.
How do they see through the night?
Guys, what's the...
What's the...
button for...
night goggles?
Guys, I should have it.
I'm part of the team.
Well, I saw them.
I saw the man.
He shot me.
I saw him.
I saw the man.
I found him, guys.
I found him.
Why do they get to defend in the day and we have to defend on the night?
This is actually not fair.
Like, what the fuck?
They literally get to play at night time?
Oh my God.
Guys, I'm just a fucking baby.
Guys, this has like...
How many reviews?
This game has like...
3,000 plus positive reviews?
Did we do it?
We did it, guys!
We did it!
Okay, I have a flashlight now.
We did it, guys.
We finally did it.
Oh my God.
We fucking did it, guys.
We figured it out.
Okay, I won't turn my lights off.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
I'm gonna run away.
Goodbye, chief.
Whoa!
There's somebody inside!
Now it's daytime!
Guys, did I do it?
Did I?
No!
Guys, do you think I did it?
Guys...
It was better, right?
Do you think it's...
You know, it was better.
I think I did a lot better.
Hey, guys.
I'm improving.
Wait, there's more people now?
How do they have more players?
How is there more people playing this game?
Okay.
I'm here with people playing this game.
No, please!
Please!
People...
I would've thought people died so fast!
Oh my God.
Guys, I think I got a kill.
Guys.
I think I got a kill, guys.
I think...
I think I did it, right?
Guys, I totally got a kill there.
Right, guys?
Let's tone down the motion here real fast.
Where the fuck is it?
Okay.
Display, graphics, display...
Was it control?
Oh, there we go.
Camera sh...
Zero camera sh...
Okay.
That shit...
Oh my God.
Did you hear that?
They're like doing like...
Intel.
Like, one more, one more.
Left side of blue.
Is that our guy?
Richard, you got this, Richard!
We got this!
We're the bad guys, but we got...
Dude, okay.
This is a very bad oil rig.
Okay?
This oil rig is owned by bad people.
So we're the good guys.
Did we win?
Did we do it?
Guys, did we do it?
Guys, did we win?
How am I minus one?
How is that possible?
How did I...
How do I lose a kill?
Oh, I killed my own teammate!
Oh!
That makes more sense now.
Actually.
Gosh, I walk so slow.
As if I'm trying to...
No!
I thought that he was part of the scenery!
I was like, whoa!
I thought that...
I thought he was part of the scenery!
I was like, whoa!
What's that?
He hit me!
Actually.
You're on my corner!
I checked my corner after...
What's that?
What the fuck?
That's cheating!
That's not realism!
That's not realism at all!
He's...
He's basic through the windows!
I am not being immersed right now.
I am...
Why am I so slow?
Do I have like... too much stuff on me?
Oh no, okay.
Okay.
It's a window.
No, he phased through!
Not realistic!
I'm un-immersed right now.
My immersion was ruined.
Did I do it?
Is he dead?
Did I do it, guys?
I think I did it.
I got a kill!
No!
It's okay.
I brought someone down with me, guys.
I think...
I think I got him.
Guys, look!
I got zero kills now!
I'm improving!
I have zero kills now!
Yay!
I got better!
Team, you guys gotta win this!
Team!
You guys gotta do this for me!
Can't go in there with my... Oh wait, no.
If they lose this, I have a chance to have one kill.
I got net zero.
Net zero KDA.
That's what I'm...
That's what I'm talking about.
Holy shit, what the fuck?
Did we do it?
No!
They did... Oh wait, no.
That's good.
I have another chance to...
I have another chance to, like, uh...
get another kill.
Okay.
Alright.
This is good.
I have another chance to get another kill now.
Can you hear me?
Guys, I think they heard me.
I...
Guys, I think... I think they heard me, guys.
Guys, I think...
I think they heard me, guys.
Someone, please!
A raid!
A pinch-bop dead body!
Guys... guys...
Guys...
guys...
I broke my drone.
I broke...
Not only...
Not only did I...
die... I also...
broke my drone.
...
Holy shit.
This game is so hard.
It's like...
It's like it's so real.
It's almost like it's...
real life.
I can't believe when you get shot by a gun...
you just die.
Like, isn't that crazy?
...
Isn't that insane?
Like, I thought...
you know, you would live like...
for like 30 more seconds longer...
and then, you know, you just get a band-aid...
and then you put the band-aid on...
you'll be okay.
Hey, I got plus 100 R!
I'm a thousand...
100 R now!
Let's go!
Rank depends on kills, deaths, and wins.
You can reduce in rank or increase...
I...
ranked up!
I'm pretty good at this game.
Guys?
Okay, no.
No.
Alright, let's actually make our...
Wait.
What the fuck?
Where am I?
Hello?
Wha...
Where am I?
How did I get here?
Yay!
I don't know how I...
What?
Where the...
Oh!
Oh, now we're even more realistic.
We're in a home!
Whoa!
We're in a home now!
Okay.
Alright, they placed the bomb.
Oh my god, this is so realistic.
Oh boy.
We have pistols though.
Whoa.
Don't worry.
Guys, I don't know what I'm doing, but I'm contributing...
to the cause.
AHHHHH!
I...
What?
What happened?
Did I got kicked out?
What?
What happened?
Did I...
Oh, I got kicked out.
Oh, was it cause he was a teammate?
Oh...
I got kicked out...
because it was a teammate.
I thought he was a...
I thought he was the enemy.
Oh no!
I'm sorry.
I was so confused.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hello, JokeyBird.
I haven't seen you in a while because of your brutal streaming hours for EU.
No!
I'm sorry!
I hate that!
Thank you for the super chat.
Why is your streamlabs donation message, Donator stole from your wallet instead of Jokey stole?
Because you stole from another person just to give money to me.
That's why.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, well...
Well, like, that was a little awkward.
I'm sorry.
No!
I can't believe it!
They fucking kicked me out!
It was too realistic!
They kicked me out!
Alright.
Let's see.
Okay, we're gonna do a tumblewood.
I'm creating my own lobby.
There we go.
Is that it?
Is that all I have to do?
I'm by myself.
I have no friends.
Oh no.
Maybe team deathmatch is pretty neat.
Yeah, maybe it is.
Yeah, maybe this is what...
Alright, I'm gonna make my own match.
You can't kick me out if I own the lobby!
That's fucking right.
You can't kick me out now.
That's fucking right!
You can't kick me out now If I own this lobby!
AHAHAHAHAHA!
aHAHAHAHAHA!
look at that 100k streamlabs!
That's fucking right!
I wanted to play the woods.
The woods was what I saw in the trailer.
It was what looked so cool!
Alright.
Let's see.
Where are the people?
Hello?
Where are you guys?
Guys, you wouldn't let me die, right?
Guys?
There's no way you can hear me.
There's no way you guys have the ears to know...
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
Is that you?
Did I get him?
Guys, I don't think I got him.
Oh, it's so real.
It's so real.
Wait, here's a drone.
I don't think he sees me.
I don't think...
I don't think he sees me, guys.
Guys, I don't think he saw me.
How did he see me?
I don't understand!
How?
How did he see me?
There's no way!
Oh my god, this is so... wait, is that my dead body?
No, I don't think I died there, right?
Where the fuck are these people?
There's no way!
He must be hacking!
How did he see me?
I can't believe he saw me!
Alan, just die so we can, like, play the game, Alan.
Alan!
Just let them kill you, it's over.
It's fucking over, Alan.
None of us have kills, Alan!
Just... just accept it!
Alright, where is he?
How are you gonna shoot any... someone from all the...
Wait, where is he?
Where... fuck, he's so far!
Alright, let's do, like, POV.
I said POV.
Alan, get there!
Get over...
Oh!
Wait, did Alan win?
Wait, Alan won!
Holy shit!
Did you let your big brother play the video game?
Okay.
Alright.
I can't believe Alan won.
He actually... we have nades?
Oh my god, we have nades.
We have nades.
Alright.
Let's just follow... let's follow Emu.
Wait, it's snowing now.
Alright.
Don't worry, I won't team kill.
I own this lobby anyway, so how am I supposed to team kill?
I think I only get, like, one bomb.
I'm pretty sure.
This shit is so...
Okay.
Guys, I'm gaming.
Guys, I don't know where he... is that him?
Is that a person?
Is that... is that a person?
Reloading.
I'm getting shot to my side.
Where?
Oh no, I'm scared.
How do you see that?
Where did he get?
Where he got shot?
Minute!
Oh, there he...
No!
Oh my god!
There is so...
Guys, the forest was a bad idea, guys.
The forest was a bad idea.
The forest.
I thought it would be cool, but...
but it's so hard to see anybody, guys.
Oh my god.
Did I kill one?
I did!
No, that's not me guys.
That's Alan and Emu.
Alright.
Wait, I have a better gun now.
Look for the movement.
But like everybody is like camouflaged.
How do I look for movement when I can barely see myself?
Okay, that's an invisible wall.
Okay, invisible walls exist in the forest.
That's good to know.
Oh my god.
This is for people who really love realism.
This shit is hard.
You actually have to be so fucking patient.
I'm one of the grass.
There's no way I'm going to die.
There's no way they see me here.
If they do, they're actually cheating.
Like...
I'm going to make noise.
Okay.
Alright.
Anybody there?
Oh, it's so scary.
It's like a horror game.
Watch my flanks.
I have to watch behind us too?
Oh my god.
Please.
We're so sneaky.
I hear no gunshots.
I'm leaning.
Oh, I hear nothing.
I don't like that.
I don't hear anything.
Guys, this is not like Apex at all.
Alright, my goal right now is to get one kill.
That's all.
I don't ask for much.
Guys, I think I'm losing blood.
Oh, I killed him!
I killed him!
I got my one kill!
Alright, this is peak gaming.
10 out of 10.
I got my one kill.
Where did I kill this?
Is that him?
What?
Was that a person?
Where did I die?
Guys, I think that was a real person.
you could...
I think that was a real person.
I don't know.
I couldn't tell.
It's so hard to tell.
Chat.
No!
I hit my head!
You peek from super obvious...
Bro, I don't know where to I...
This is my first time on this map!
It's so scary!
Oh my god, this game is actually Oh my god, this game is actually fucking...
It's like half horror.
The tree is talking.
Cause it's like...
It's trees were all so camouflaged too!
Peak gaming were like peak dying.
I gotta like become one with the trees!
I don't understand!
How did he know?
I don't understand.
Holy shit!
I just need you guys to know My PC is on overdrive trying to run this game right now.
Oh my god!
This is literally like the gaming stress test.
Joe, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
I love that scene in Saving Private Ryan too.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
How hot is it?
Oh yeah, like the top part?
Yeah, it's...
Yeah!
I'm hitting the floor!
Oh, goodbye.
No, I can actually hear him bleed out!
Did you guys hear that?
Holy shi- What the fuck?
You can like hear him bleed out!
Oh!
Jeez!
That's...
That's like...
Ugh!
Okay.
Alright, 10.
Alright.
They bleed out!
That's so realistic!
I'm gonna run.
There's no way.
Okay, wait, wait.
How do I prone?
Is there prone here?
In this game?
Oh my god.
This is for people who wanna be like super serious.
Where are we running to?
I don't know.
I'm letting my legs take me to places where I never knew existed.
Hahaha!
I'm letting...
I'm letting fate take me where every...
Oh!
You think I got him?
No.
You think they know I'm here?
You...
I don't think they knew.
Guys, I don't think they knew.
Guys, no no no no no.
I don't think they knew guys.
I can keep walking.
They don't know.
Oh!
They don't know chat.
I can keep sneaking behind them.
Yes, they don't know.
Oh shit!
Stop!
Leave me alone!
Drop!
You're gonna ruin my surprise!
Stop!
You have a flashlight!
Hahaha!
Wait, that's the enemy drone.
Oh shit!
I think they're gonna know now.
Oh no.
No, they don't know I'm here guys.
There's no way.
They're not gonna tell them that I'm here.
There's no way they're gonna tell them.
Where are they?
They said body's here.
Dragonborn Emu!
That's my teammate.
Oh no!
Ah!
He whiffed and then I whiffed!
And then he got me!
No!
Hahaha!
We both whiffed!
But he whiffed less!
Hahaha!
No!
Kick him out!
He's too good!
Hahaha!
I refuse to let these good players!
And I'm joking.
Oh there he is.
No!
I bumped my head on a tree!
Hahaha!
Oh we did it!
We won!
Yippee!
Oh wait I can!
Wait can I actually kick people out?
That would be pretty funny.
Wait can I?
Can I actually?
What if I just swap teams?
What if I?
Hahaha!
What if I just leave this team?
Toki no!
I can switch teams whenever I want!
Hahaha!
Alright if this team starts losing we're swapping.
You went when you should have!
Nay nay!
Can't say thank you in the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh my god what gun is this?
I'm gonna look at my controls.
Guys!
Truce!
The host has to look at her controls real quick.
Key bindings.
Okay we have fire, aim, flashlight, inspect, drop items, swap, jump, jog.
We have jog?
What does jog look like?
What's the difference between jog and sprint?
It's the same speed!
Okay.
I hear him.
Like right over here.
I don't know.
There's no way they know.
I'm like super silent.
There's no way I can...
I don't know.
I got him!
I think I got him!
Oh my god I'm better!
I'm so much better!
I fucking did it!
I sneaked!
I sneaked it!
Okay.
Alright we're winning this.
They don't know.
They don't fucking know.
I'm part of the fucking rocks.
I'm part of the rocks.
Okay.
Where are they?
Hello?
Hello guys!
Where's my teammate?
I think what I'm scared about is that I don't know where my teammates are.
I don't know if I'm the last remaining...
I'm the last remaining guy here.
That's so slow.
Oh I hear shots in front of me.
I hear shots.
Okay slow and steady.
They won't know I'm part of the bushes.
I'm part of the trees.
That person?
No.
Sneaky sneaky.
But I also don't know either.
Is that a person?
Did I?
No.
Oh no I heard gunshots this way too.
Am I the last one?
No!
I can't believe it!
I was the last one!
No!
SarahFace says no.
They can put the 20, get the chest!
Thank you, thank you.
Bro they naded me?
How?
Okay.
Don't worry I got my own nade too emu.
Don't worry.
I'm holding it right now.
I think.
Don't worry, Emu.
I got a nade as well.
I got you.
Where are they?
Holy shit.
Don't worry, Emu.
I got you.
I have a nade as well.
No matter what happens, Emu, I will throw my nade for you.
I'll throw my nade and then you do the rest.
Did we do it?
Emu, did we do it?
I can't tell.
Did we do it?
Is he dead?
Emu, I'm bleeding out.
Emu, I need you.
I'm bleeding out, Emu.
No, I didn't do it!
I'm bleeding out.
I broke the camera though.
I did my job.
I broke the camera, but I'm definitely gonna die.
Emu, please.
I'm gonna die, Emu.
I'm slowly bleeding out.
Oh no, I feel so cold.
What did I steal?
Oh, it's the same gun.
Emu, please.
It's getting so cold, Emu!
I'm... thank you for the superchat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's getting so cold.
I think I see the light.
That was a friendly drone?
All drones are unfriendly.
There's no such thing as a friendly drone.
Oh!
My little head!
Also a friendly drone.
That's not friendly!
No!
The drone distracted me!
I was looking at the drone!
It's not fair.
I was looking at the fucking drone.
I was like, oh hey, that's not a friendly drone.
The fuck is that?
Yes, he's over here!
I'm over here!
Guys, Emo!
Emo!
He's over here, Emo!
Right here!
Emo, please!
Clutch this!
At least I'm not that guy with zero kills.
I think he just joined the lobby.
At least I'm not like him.
It's okay.
If all else fails, I can always switch teams.
Oh, I can do a light!
He's right here!
He's right here, Emo!
Lord Flamo!
Who the fuck?
Wait, Emo's dead?
He's right here!
Oh my god, please!
Look at each other!
Did we do it?
We did it!
Let's go!
Alright, boys.
We did it.
We're spread out.
Alright, let's go.
We're doing it.
Daniel, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Wait, oh my god.
I thought I had like proximity chat on this entire time.
Because the left side started going...
Daniel, sorry.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
But it was just that one guy.
That was talking to us.
I was like, oh my god, they heard me screaming this entire time.
I was like...
No.
No, I'm not.
I'm not.
Oh, thank god.
Dude, I didn't imagine if I was though.
I was like, actually like, oh my god, was I open mic this entire time?
Wait, you can use proximity chat to troll them?
Oh my god, let's do it.
Okay, when I die, we're gonna troll the other guys.
Okay.
We're fine.
Oh, we have an AK.
I think this is an AK.
I mean, it has that brown thing.
Oh my god, I'm stuck.
These trees.
These god damn trees.
Okay.
Who's that behind me?
I hear people.
What?
What the fuck?
Die!
What?
That was so fast!
Bro, that got one tapped me!
They're in the trees.
Wait, where is the...
Where's my teammate?
Okay.
Wait, wait, wait.
What are you doing?
Bro, what the...
Go up!
Go up...!
Wait, where's the enemy?
Where's the enemy?
I lost the... Oh, he's right here!
We only have... It's a 1v1, I think.
Boo!
Boo.
Please!
Oh thank god, okay I just got him.
He killed the other one.
The other drone.
That's hilarious.
Yay!
I helped!
Guys, help!
The drone keeps saying boo!
Not the drone.
Guys, I helped!
Guys, the distraction!
The distraction works!
The distraction works, guys!
I told you!
It fucking works!
That was the most fun.
Like as long as I can terrorize other people, that's all.
I'm happy.
As long as I can grief in some shape or form, I'm satisfied.
Okay.
The tea bag of the drone.
Wait, can I like clip through this?
Okay.
New meta.
Oh my god, I see him.
Oh my god, I feel like he's gonna hit me.
I'm gonna get cover here.
Whoa.
I'm so scared.
No, what?!
Holy shit!
He shot me from all the way there?!
Oh, it's okay.
Wait, who killed me?
Holy shit!
He's over... okay.
Don't worry.
Oh, no, he really doesn't want me alive.
Oh, he's trying to kill me now.
Okay.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, he's trying to kill this drone.
Whoa!
Guys, I'm scared.
This guy actually...
Ah, no!
I...
I landed on...
I crashed into the floor.
I crashed into the fucking floor.
DW, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome!
Oh my god!
I crashed into the floor!
I can't believe it.
I can't believe it!
Alright.
Okay guys, we gotta... we gotta be a team guys.
We gotta work together everybody!
I'm surprised another drone crashed onto the floor cause she wanted to yell boo.
We can't always have nice things chat.
Okay.
Alright.
It's snowing again.
Oh it's always snowing on Mount Fuji.
Okay there's no way they can see me with their special eyes.
Guys I...
Okay I have the least kills.
Okay.
Never mind.
How are these people so good at this game?
It's like... it's like they've actually played tactical shooters!
How are they so tactical?
I don't understand.
How are these people so fucking goddamn tact...
No!
I saw him!
I saw him too!
But he saw me first!
He fucking saw me first!
Ah, damn it!
I stared at him... and he stared at me.
I know my place.
And it's a drone.
It's okay.
I'm here to provide intel.
I provide intel guys.
Right here where is he?
I'm the intel provider.
I know my worth.
Where is he though?
I hear him.
Boo.
Hey.
He's over here.
No!
Stop it.
No fun!
I can't believe it!
My team hit me!
My drone!
Damage!
I can't believe I got hit by the Kalei!
That's unfair!
I got hit by the Kalei.
It's too realistic.
What the fuck?
They're actually strategizing?
I don't know what I'm doing.
What do you mean?
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
I'm just fucking existing.
Yeah.
Don't worry, Emu.
You and me.
Actual comms, I know, right?
Oh my god, this other guy is talking a lot though.
Just hug the trees.
I see them.
I don't think he sees me.
I'm gonna stay behind this big tree just in case.
Oh no, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Mr. Kra- I don't wanna get accidentally headshot!
Okay.
Safe tree.
Oh my god, this tree is safe.
Hello?
This is my safe tree.
Is somebody to my left?
I'm so scared.
I don't feel safe, guys.
I call this my safe tree, but for some reason, this does not feel safe.
Oh god.
Is that my drone?
No, it's not.
Wait, he's like...
Wait, did you hear that?
The drone was like...
Oh my god.
Where is it?
Then he got shot.
Famous last words.
My safe tree.
My safety place.
I'm so scared.
You gotta come to me if you wanna kill me.
Oh no.
Yeah, come over here.
Behind the safe tree.
They're like somewhere over on the side.
They're stealing my tactics.
I mean, to be fair, they were pretty good tactics, so...
Did he know?
Can you see me?
No!
I left the safety of the trees.
I left...
Never leave the trees.
Who?
Hahahaha!
Did you guys hear that?
Did you...
Did you guys hear him?
He was like...
leave me alone.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he was like, leave me alone!
Hahahaha!
Oh my god.
What a menace!
Wait, where is he?
I don't want to leave him alone after you said that.
Now I definitely won't leave him.
No!
Guys, I bumped into a tree.
The voices, make it stop!
Make the...
Make the voices stop!
Alright, which way is right?
This way.
Okay.
The tree...
VH, VH...
And now I don't want to leave him alone.
I don't know if like running straight right is like the best idea.
But okay.
Is this cover?
Whoa!
What if they ran left?
I'm scared.
Guys, I'm scared.
Guys.
I'm scared.
I'm only helpful in drone form.
Guys, I don't know when I'm physical.
But I'm...
What do I do when I'm a physical flesh being?
I'm not used to this.
I don't see them.
Wait, my teammates are dead.
My teammates are dead.
Where are they?
Oh no, Emu.
I'm scared, Emu.
Wait, that's... Those are enemy drones.
Emu, I'm scared.
Where are they?
Where's left flank?
Oh!
That's my right!
What do you mean left flank?
That's my right side!
On his left!
That's the fucking right side!
It's...
On their left!
Front!
I assume he's gonna use my directions!
What the fuck do you mean left?
I see...
Oh my god!
I got a kill!
I got... I did it!
Boo!
Guys,
I don't think they like you.
Guys, I don't think they like me.
Every time he got me.
It's okay guys.
But what if I swap teams?
What if I just switch teams?
Did I swap?
Oh my god, did I actually swap?
Where am I?
Wait, how do I swap?
How do I swap?
Swap!
No!
It's full!
I just wanted to be...
Whoa!
No!
Never say thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
Rookie mistake.
I assume Doki is facing the enemies.
No!
I wanna be on their team!
Cause they're winning!
I just wanna be a winner!
Okay, I'm gonna follow Alan and get him killed.
Doki can't be cool.
Okay, but what if like... I'm gonna hide behind that big tree.
There's no way they know I'm here.
A big tree.
Oh, I hear people dead.
This is the comeback of the century.
As soon as I figure out how to get past this tree.
Cause it ain't looking so good for me right now.
Oh no.
I saw that... the guy that was like, leave me alone!
That's the lizard free in my head.
That shit was so funny.
Leave me alone.
Alright.
So realistic.
He doesn't know I'm here.
They got the kill?
I did!
I got the kill!
I fled, guys!
I'm one with the... wait, what the fuck?
Bro, what the...
Bro, I'm bad at shooting drones!
Leave me alone!
Oh, I got it.
Okay, I'm good at this.
Guys, I got the drone.
Alright.
Where is he?
I'm one with the grass.
I don't know where he is.
That's what scares me.
Where are they?
Am I the only one left?
I think I'm the only one left.
I'm the only one left.
Oh no.
Where's my teammates?
Tell me where they are.
Oh shit!
Guys, you're supposed to tell me where they are!
Not the explosion!
It's supposed to be me!
You fuckers!
Bro, why are you exposing my position?
You're supposed to be helping me!
Where are they?
He's over there.
I got him!
That's five?
Wait, there's more?
Where's the last guy?
Okay.
No!
Fuck off!
Stop!
AHHHHH!
No!
No, I got shot, I got shot, I got shot.
Oh no, oh no, oh no, oh no.
Yeah, what the...
The other drone!
I even got two kills!
From the other drone!
I got a drone kill!
Is that fair?!
I got killed so hard!
Holy shit!
I got killed so...
I even got two kills too!
That's bullshit!
Guess how the Terry Bulls have turned.
Now I know, now I know why that guy was so mad.
Now I know why the other guy was so annoyed with me.
I know how he feels now.
Okay, I'm in the open.
This is not good.
I need to find cover.
Fast.
No.
I'm getting stuck.
Oh god, this is cover.
Oh no.
Oh, no.
Okay, that's my teammate.
I would try not to do Friendly Five.
Oh, no.
I'm getting better though!
I'm improving!
Oh, at least I'm improving.
Chat.
I'm one with our bushes.
Oh no, I don't feel safe.
I don't feel safe.
I need this tree.
No, no, no, no, no.
This tree isn't part of this.
This tree is out.
The tree is outside.
Oh no.
I see him.
I tried to ping.
I don't know why I tried to ping.
I hear... No!
Did I get him?
I don't know.
I think so.
Dragon, it's you and me.
No, no, no, no, no.
Oh no.
Dragon, I hope I die first so you have to clutch it.
Am I bleeding?
Woo!
I'm so scared.
I don't know if I can move out of this position, dragon.
No!
I'm so god damn drawn!
Oh my god!
The fucking drawn faded me!
I can't believe it!
I actually believe it.
I can't believe it.
I'm so fucking faded.
I can't... Bro!
How are you so smart?
I got drawn so hard!
Oh my god!
Get drawn, nerd!
I can't believe it.
I can't bel...
I can't believe I got faded by the fucking drone!
And then they destroyed my drone so fast.
Hey bro!
It's over.
GG's guys Thought it was a 4 to 10 My God!
I can't believe it.
I got RP, though!
I got rank points from it!
I think I did pretty well.
I was not bottom fag.
Somebody did worse than me!
I can't believe this game.
Somebody did worse to me.
I saw it.
I saw it, guys.
Wait, how do I leave?
How the fuck do I...
Guys, the game bugged out, guys.
I can't even leave this live.
Holy shit.
It like bugged out so I can't leave the live.
Oh, no!
No.
Oh, God.
Okay, I have to turn...
Oh, my God.
It like auto plays.
That shit auto plays.
I'm the host but it won't...
It won't even...
I can't leave.
I actually can't leave.
I'm stuck here.
I'm actually stuck here.
I'm stuck forever.
We can't even start the lobby.
We have to reset the game.
I'm actually... I can't even like...
I can't even like start the lobby.
I actually have to reset.
Alright.
Okay.
There was like one of the maps I really want to play too.
There was another map I want to play.
It was like the... what was it?
It was like tactical training shit with all the wood stuff.
Okay.
Alright, let's make sure I don't play this.
And then...
Lobby.
Okay.
Start match.
Host map.
Okay.
Alright.
I really want to try...
Alright, should we do body planting or deathmatch, guys?
Team deathmatch or body plant?
What should we do?
Or body bomb?
I went to the airsoft house.
Wait.
Hahaha.
Body or deathmatch?
Deathmatch for the chaos team.
Okay.
We'll do...
Oh my gosh, the abandoned hospital looks so fun too.
We'll do house.
We'll do airsoft house first.
And then we'll try the abandoned hospital and the planting one.
Actually, oh my gosh.
I don't know.
Which is better, guys?
Should team deathmatch...
be on the house?
Airsoft house or the hospital?
What should we do?
Hospital or airsoft house?
For team deathmatch.
Airsoft?
Okay.
Airsoft house.
We'll try.
This shit is intense.
Alright, here we go.
Vroom.
Let's go!
To the... Let's jump to the airsoft...
Me and my homies.
Parachuting to the airsoft house.
Parachuting over there.
Nice.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Just like in real life.
Just like...
Ooh.
Oh my god, this shit is...
Oh, this shit is intense.
Because there's like fake people too.
Who is here?
What the fuck?
Is that person?
No, that's not.
That's so...
Okay, that's scary.
What?
What do you mean?
No.
You shot your own teammate, you idiot.
But we won.
You fucking...
Why'd you turn...
Because I couldn't see.
What do you mean?
Alan fucking shot me!
Oh, this shit is intense though.
Jesus Christ.
That shit scares me.
That person?
Wait, the drone...
The drone is like using its lights.
Somebody there.
No!
Double tap.
Oh.
Oh, this is scary.
Oh, please.
Oh.
This is intense.
Oh god.
Holy shit, this is intense.
I hear him, he's over there.
Drones, find him!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
He's to my left.
I hear him.
Oh, I hear him.
God, that scared me.
Where is he?
Oh.
You fucker!
Okay.
Okay, let's hope that guy didn't find me.
Oh my god.
It's whoever finds each other first.
Wait, this is much more intense than the forest, guys.
This is so much more intense than the forest, chat.
I hear him.
It's like close by.
Oh my god.
You saw him?
Where?
Oh no.
I saw him too.
Wait, I just saw him.
Did you guys see him?
I saw him right there.
To your left, I think the other...
Guys, no, don't say that.
Don't do this to me.
He was above.
He was above the house.
Oh my god.
Why?
This is so tense!
Oh my god.
Okay.
I hate this.
Oh my god, I'm so tensed up.
There's fall damage.
No.
It's so...
There's fall damage.
This is so
life.
It's so...
Oh my god.
It's so real that there's fall damage.
Holy shit.
What is this?
Bullshit.
What the fuck is this?
I'm still crying about the fall damage.
No!
I crashed!
How did I crash?
What?
I flew one centimeter and I spiraled.
How?
No.
It's all falling apart.
Oh my god.
Everything is falling apart.
Chat.
Holy shit.
That shit is brutal.
That shit is actually brutal.
I see him.
No!
I shot the pillar!
Holy shit.
Spark flew out of there.
I was the last one?
Guys.
2, 4, 5, 2, 4...
Damn it.
I can't swap teams.
God fucking damn it.
I can't do what I wanted to do.
The pillar protects.
No!
He's so good!
It's okay.
My job.
Oh shit.
Oh!
Oh, he's over here!
He's over here!
No!
Hahaha!
Nice.
It's okay.
I got...I distracted two people.
Hahaha!
That's okay.
I got...oh my god.
Is that my body?
Over there?
I got two assists, guys.
That's all that matters.
I contributed.
Hahaha!
Bro, what the fuck?
That's my dead body.
That's fucked up.
Holy shit.
This map is actually so intense though.
We've had enough of your shenanigans, Doki.
We had enough.
Why do you be a contributor so little?
I helped.
At least I got one kill.
At least I got one kill, guys.
That's all that matters.
The moral support.
The blur on the left?
Oh wait, that's just so we don't dox people.
You know, because this is... we're basically... you know how like we're controlling...
Uh...
What the fuck happened to that drone?
So like we're actually controlling like...
Uh...
We're like implants in like military men and we're like controlling them right now.
Oh my god, you're bleeding!
Medic!
This is real life.
This is not a simulation.
So we gotta... we gotta make sure... we gotta make sure we don't accidentally dox them.
Bro, you're gonna bleed out!
Look at the trail of blood behind you!
Dude, you're gonna bleed out before you get to anybody!
Like, fucking rip off your shirt and tie it like... and soak up that blood!
Bro, look at your trail of blood.
Bro is fucking...
leaking a trail.
Holy shit!
He's gonna bleed out before like anybody shoots him.
I'm mortal.
But they're just gonna follow this trail of blood.
He's leaving a little treasure hunt for... is he gonna die?
Oh, I thought he was just gonna start passing out.
He almost shot Alan!
It's like, you know like those children mazes?
Those coloring books in like children mazes?
This is like his coloring book right now.
He's trying to find the exit chat...
He's trying to find the exit.
Wait...
Almost friendly fire!
What are you doing?
Wait, where are you...
Bro, he...
AHH!
What are you... what are you doing?
What did I want?
He got shot in front of him and he looked behind.
No!
Bro is playing turf war.
Why he turned around?
To be fair, he lost a lot of blood.
You're right, you're right guys.
You're right.
That is fair.
He did lose a lot of blood.
He did not know where he was going.
He was losing a lot of blood there.
Jesus.
That's a lot of gunshots.
Shadow don't die!
I'm watching you!
Wait, what?
He got shot.
But from where?
Did I shoot you?
Oh no, I'm bleeding.
Oh no.
Guys.
My trail of blood.
Not looking too good for me.
It's not looking too good for Doki.
Is that the good guy flashlight or the bad guy flashlight?
It's time to find out.
No!
I'm the Picasso now.
Wait, I was the last?
Guys, we're not very good.
I'm gonna say it guys.
Our teammate looks so good.
Chat.
Our team is struggling right now.
Oh.
I just saw him die.
Bro, he's like shooting me through walls.
What the f- I'm sprinkling blood!
I'm coughing blood right now!
Where?
Oh shit.
I hope- Okay guys, I got him.
It's fine, I killed him.
Bro, where's the Medic?
Guys, I think they're better than us.
Guys.
I have a feeling.
Maybe it's high ground advantage, chat.
Maybe it's just high ground advantage, you know?
Maybe we're not bad, they just have high ground.
Like we all have high ground.
Y'all know high ground advantage is strong.
It's not...
Shit.
Holy shit.
That was scary.
What
do you mean, oh?
What do you mean, oh?
What do you mean by oh?
Guys, I'm scared.
What?
How did he know?
Wait, he was inside too?
Oh my god, he's over here.
He's in the shadows.
Oh wait,
we all died.
Okay.
It didn't matter.
Okay, there we go.
I'm gonna do something great.
Oh wait, that's you.
Oh, he's over here in the corner.
He's on the second floor.
He's out running down the stairs.
He's not...
Oh my god.
He's off the...
He's mad.
I think he's...
He didn't like it.
The world's strongest drone.
Dang.
I can't believe it.
Got down in the boo drone.
The fucking boo drone.
It's the only way to win.
See, we're one to eight.
What do you want us to do?
He's mad.
Guys, we're one to eight.
We gotta...
Do what we can.
To like, get something.
We're gonna hit down the stairs.
I've had enough of being upstairs.
Oh my god.
Okay, we'll go back upstairs.
Did I sh...
Did I get him?
Oh, I think I got him.
Yeah!
Is that a guy over there?
I got him.
I did it!
Guys, I'm getting better!
I got three kills!
What the fuck have you guys been doing?
Woo!
One shot, one kill.
Okay.
I feel safer over here.
Guns are loud.
Guns are so loud.
Who are they shooting?
Who the fuck are they trying to shoot?
There's only two of us left.
Three of us.
I'm not peeking.
What if I...
Okay, I'm not gonna risk it again.
I was gonna say, what if I just drop down?
Then like, I remember what happened when I just dropped down.
Wait.
There's someone over there.
Oh.
There is.
No.
No!
I was the last one!
Wait, I got two...
I got another kill!
Okay, I got a kill.
Guys, I got another kill.
Guys, it's the last game, guys.
It's the last game.
Oh my god.
I got another kill though.
I'm gaming.
I'm gonna head downstairs.
I think...
Whatever gun I had that got me those four kills, that was clutch.
That was my favorite gun.
Not gonna lie.
Whichever gun that was.
Nevermind.
Oh!
He's over here!
Bottom floor!
On the left!
Or my right.
Okay.
Wait.
Bro.
All the...
Guys, the enemy is on the other side.
Woo!
Second floor!
Guys, they're on the other side.
They're on the other side.
Second floor!
Floor!
Oh no!
You're the last one!
Clutch your kick!
No, he's on the third floor.
He's... oh he's dead.
Woah, you did it!
Bro, the other enemy drone was giving him intel and then he just dies.
He actually clutched it!
Oh my god, he clutched it!
That's crazy!
I did not expect that.
I did not expect the clutch.
He did clutch your kick, guys!
He did it!
We were like, clutch your kick and he actually clutched.
Where are these shots?
That's not a real person.
No!
I'm bleeding.
Guys, oh no.
My trail of blood remembers me.
I'm bleeding.
Oh no.
Oh, he's second floor.
Guys, I'm bleeding so much.
Guys, is this the enemy drone?
Oh, we did it!
We won!
Yeah!
Holy shit.
We did it.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna press shift tab.
So you saw my mic settings.
Oh my god.
They won't expect that.
Guys, look!
I'm actually doing...
He's over here.
Woo!
You can't hear the sounds of the footsteps.
I can't believe it.
I can't.
I just wanted to look at my soun...
I just wanted to look at my sound settings!
Noooo!
I just wanted to look at my sound.
I just wanted to look at my, like,
That's all I'm going to say.
That's all I'm gonna say.
I did pretty well.
Okay, I want to do a body bomb.
Okay, I feel like Abandoned Hospital...
I think like this is too much camping.
I think this is too much camping.
It's not as fun because you're camping.
So I think like Team Deathmatch is actually pretty fun.
Yeah, improved a lot.
I think I improved a lot.
All right.
Time to go to the Abandoned Hospital!
Let's go!
Holy shit!
Wait, this is... guys, this is pretty spooky.
This is pretty spooky guys.
Wait, they have all the good players!
Wait, wait, wait a minute.
Before it's too late.
NOOOOOO!
Nooooo!
All the good players are on the enemy team!
This is not fair!
Wait, this is so spooky.
Holy shit.
This one's intense.
This one's pretty intense, not gonna lie.
It's over there.
You go first, Shadow.
You'll be too busy shooting.
Jesus Christ, what do I have?
A fucking deagle?
That's so loud!
Ho
ho ho!
Jesus Christ!
That gun was so fucking loud!
Wait, where is he?
Bro, this is so... this is... this is intense.
I was like... bom bom!
I was like, what the fuck?!
AAH!
Guys, I hit my head again.
I hit..
We're taking fun of 10 gifted ships!
Thank you!
Guys, I can't believe guns are loud in real life.
You're like the only one left, guys.
Guns in Dora are really loud.
Oh my god.
It's crazy.
No way.
This realism...
Holy shit!
Holy fuck!
Guys, this realism shooter is so realistic.
Who would've thought?
Oh my god.
Let me fucking adjust that.
Like an actual cannon.
That's a big boy gun, right?
Right there.
For big boys!
Alright.
Oh my god, this is so...
This is actually harder.
Okay.
Okay, I'll stop walking.
Oh my god.
Hello...
AHH!
Wait.
Why am I actually shooting my gun?
Wait, what?
I accidentally...
My gun actually...
Guys, my gun jammed!
It jammed itself!
It's so realistic!
I got a gun jam!
Guys, I think Alan's dead in front of me.
Guys, I think he's dead.
Now he's dead too.
Oh?
Hello?
Oh my god, I swear they did the bait again.
HAHAHAHAHA!
He did the fucking...
...uh...
The bait again on me?
Oh, I hear somebody.
Okay.
Did I do it?
Oh my god, he's groaning.
Oh my god.
He's right there.
He's right there!
Oh.
He's not there?
Where is he?
I wait.
Where is he, guys?
I scared him.
I'm scared.
Oh...
Where is he?
Come on.
I can wait forever.
I'm patient.
I'll never move.
What the fuck?
Holy shit he fucking just ran!
I was like what the fuck is that?
What the fuck was that?
He went so fast!
He literally ran!
I was so confused!
I was like what the fuck just ran past me?
Look I got us three kills there guys.
I got us fucking three kills.
I did my job.
Dude went full Leeroy.
I was like what the fuck was that?
But that guy like actually just ran straight past me.
It like freaked me out as I didn't expect it.
I'm so sorry.
It like came out of nowhere.
What's he doing?
Oh god.
No!
What is that?
Who shot me?
Was there two people there?
I didn't check my corner if there were two people!
No!
What the fuck doing a little jiggy dance here?
He's camping!
Alan he's camping!
He's camping in the bookshelves!
Alan!
That's awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
That was funny.
All the drones were like, what the fuck?
Airport, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Doors and corners, that's where it gets you.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe you guys traded.
And then all the drones just stopped and looked at it and was like, what the fuck happened?
What the fuck happened there?
Okay.
Okay, the beginning of this game is when we were starting to learn it was rough because we were learning.
But the longer we played, the funnier this game gets.
That was so anticlimactic.
Yeah.
The first, just for VOD watchers out there, for people who just got here and were like, oh, should I wash in the bag?
The first couple of games, the first few rounds, we were still learning.
So it was pretty rough.
We didn't know what the fuck we're doing.
But then as we started learning, it's when we got to the forest is when we started getting, we started light bulb.
Yeah, once you start to understand it.
All right, guys.
Guys, I want to swap teams.
Bro, one of them has seven kills.
What if I just leave you guys and make my other new lobby?
Guys, I want to get carried.
No swapping, coward.
Where's your loyalty?
We're getting all three.
There's no loyalty when you start getting all three.
Oh, my God.
All right.
I'm noticing.
Yeah.
Alan.
Alan's the common demon.
When he's on my team, I lose.
It's not the other way around.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Somebody died there.
Okay.
All I'm saying is the pattern here is Alan, not me.
Look, I have three killers guys.
Oh.
Whoa.
Whoa, I think that's a person over there, guys.
Guys, I think he's trying to shoot me.
But what if like...
What if I just stand here?
There's no way he's gonna land that nade.
What if I just stand right here?
Is that person over there?
Oh god.
Oh god, that's Alan!
That's me, you fucker!
Alan, you fucking idiot!
He shot me!
I told you!
I called you, elevator!
It was not me!
It was Alan!
I told you!
I fucking told you!
I knew it wasn't me.
I fucking knew it wasn't me!
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Wait, wait, wait.
Where's the enemy?
I fucking knew it.
I knew it.
Oh god.
It's one person!
Run at him!
You'll be fine!
Oh god.
No!
Not me!
I was trying to help you!
I was trying to help!
Please, someone kill him.
Please.
It's one person.
Yes!
I can't believe it!
He let him...
If I didn't care so much about my KDA, I would have shot him right there.
To be fair to you, I was there for like the entire time!
I kept him my entire game!
Oh god.
I feel like the abandoned hospital is scarier than... is scary though.
I feel like the abandoned hospital is scarier than...
is scary though.
I'm gonna go around.
Alright.
I'm gonna go this way.
Well, Alan's dead.
That was fast.
That was a very fast death for Alan.
Does he see me?
Ba ba ba da ba ba ba da ba ba.
What the fuck?
What the fuck was he doing there?
Is that good?
Good drone?
Bad drone?
Good drone or bad drone?
What the... Oh my god.
Well, he's dead.
Guys, I...
I think Shadow's gonna die soon, guys.
Shhh.
Wait, my friend's dead.
Oh shit.
He doesn't know.
I can't see.
If I can't see where they are, he can't either.
Guys, please.
Fuck off!
Stop.
Stop, you fuckers.
Fuck off!
No!
No no no no!
I'm bleeding so much.
I'm bleeding so much, guys.
This might be the end of me, guys.
This could be the end of me.
This could be the end of me, guys.
Guys, I'm not doing so well.
I'm not doing...
Guys, I'm bleeding a lot, guys.
I'm bleeding so much.
They gotta find me first.
I'm despairing so heavily.
That one drone was like, hey looks like Dusty Little's underwear.
That one drone over there is like what you doing over here?
This is the end.
This is the end everybody.
There's no... we're at an abandoned hospital, but there's no bandages!
Is there no medical supplies in this abandoned hospital?
Hey guys, I'm seeing some colors right now.
I ain't looking so good.
Oh no, I ain't looking so good, guys.
I'm seeing... oh... someone please.
I need a blood transplant.
I need a blood transplant, please.
Oh no.
I'm breathing so heavily.
Please put me out of my misery.
We're...
Oh my god.
Alright, well somebody put me out of my misery.
That's good.
I've got my...
It's okay, they put me out of my misery.
We're gonna rush.
We're rushing B.
I don't care anymore.
I'm gonna rush B.
Let's go!
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go!
What?
Why does this one guy...
Alright.
Wait, did we kick him out?
Wait, we actually kicked him out!
Oh my god!
You thought team killing the host was a good idea.
Hmm...
Toki, please.
We're already losing!
What do we lose?
Nothing!
We lose nothing for that.
Dude, I can't kick people on the enemy team.
If I could, I would.
Alright, Mr. Chucky.
You better impress me, you know.
Team killing the host?
That's wild.
Ellen, if you do it...
Ellen, if you team kill me again...
Ellen...
If you team kill me again...
I don't care.
I don't fucking care.
There he is.
I'm gonna tell somebody that he's over here.
There must be a person here.
I'll be like, follow me.
I know where people are.
Okay.
Where are they?
I wish I could threaten to kick the enemy team as well.
And be like, if you kill me, I'm gonna kick you.
To the enemy team.
Where is...
Oh my god, there's like...
Is that dead body there?
Where is that?
Where are the...
Doki, what the fuck?
Guys...
Yeah, I'll do it.
But I can't.
The game already Doki-proofed.
The game Doki-proofed already.
So I can't...
I can't kick the enemy team.
I would if I could.
I would 100%.
100% do it.
You know I would.
You know I would, chat.
I would fucking do it.
I put you out of your misery.
What?
What did you mean?
Chat, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't believe it.
They knew my plan.
Guys, this emo guy fucking has one death.
What are we doing?
What are we fucking doing?
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
I was following...
I didn't tell you to shoot me.
I told you to shoot Alan.
What the fuck was that?
Oh no.
Some guy is being too realistic with this game.
He was like, shut, shut up.
Shut the fuck up.
Oh my god.
He was like...
Oh wait, there he is.
Why are you shooting?
Did you get him?
Okay, I don't think he got him.
I don't think he got him.
Bro!
This guy is too good!
Somebody stop him!
Okay, we all rush B.
Guys, we all rush B.
Oh wait, we're on the other side.
Wait, this is...
We all rush, we rush, we run, we run!
He can't Dragoon!
Dragonborn can't kill us all!
Okay, maybe he can.
Guys, maybe he can kill us all.
I got a little scared when I saw him shooting through the hallway.
Chat.
I got a little scared.
I don't know, it just didn't seem right.
I didn't shoot him!
Where is he?
That had to be the emo guy.
That had to be him.
That shot clearly landed!
That shot was such a land.
I refuse to believe it didn't land.
How did... yes, how did none of it hit?
There's no way!
What are you guys trying to shoot?
There's nobody there.
Oh my god.
What happened here?
What the fuck happened here?
Holy shit.
Is this what happened when I was like rushed here and then like everybody rushed here except for me?
Is that what happened?
He's built different.
Bro, he's still alive.
He still has one death.
That means he's still alive, chat.
Guys, he's still alive!
He's roaming the halls!
He's still alive!
I hate that it touched the ground like once and then my drone dies.
I can't believe it.
This is the military!
We spent billions of dollars on drones We spent billions of dollars on drones for just a drone to touch the floor and it died?
Like, what's the point of spending billions of dollars?
What's the point of spending billions of dollars?
Do you know how much the US military spends on the budget?
spends on the budget?
How is this military grade?
I can't believe it.
I can't believe this is military grade.
Truly like real life.
Military grade don't mean shit.
I swear, this game...
This game is like actually a microwave.
For my PC!
Oh my god!
I don't think it's helping that playing all of this on epic graphics.
Hey, but it looks good.
It looks pretty good though.
Not gonna lie.
This is my stress test.
This game is my stress test game.
We know how...
Whoa!
He's right there!
No!
Is that him?
Did he live again?
Bro!
It's him!
You know it's him cause he has 14 kills now!
Who's he?
What am I spectating?
Who is this?
What is he seeing?
Oh my god.
It's always him.
Can I swap teams?
Please.
Can someone leave?
Can somebody leave on the end of the video?
Hey guys.
It would be so funny if someone just leaves.
Please.
It would be so hilarious.
Shoutout.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You said and I quote put me out of my misery.
Good soldiers follow orders.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Hey.
Hey guys.
Drag.
Okay.
If you are a real dragoon you would leave the enemy.
Someone on the enemy team would leave.
Right.
Oh my god.
He did it.
Holy.
I've always believed in you.
I God can bleed.
He bleeds.
Guys.
He.
Wait.
Nooooooo.
.
No, please, please, please, please...
Okay, if you were a real dragoon, you would also leave again.
If you were a real dragoon, another person would leave.
Just take the L.
All I'm saying is...
Any real gooners out there?
Any real...
Any real gooners?
Toki, what?
Any real dragooners out there?
Any real gooners?
No, because I still have 6 kills.
What?
Oh, my God!
No... NOOOOO!
I hit the ceiling!
Kaiori, I decided to leave because it's getting really late for me.
But thank you so much for the games, Toki.
It's fun as fuck to troll you.
Kaiori, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
NOOOOO!
Wow!
Now Jam's gonna get a free win!
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Silly dookie.
That's one of Murphy's rule of combat.
Never forget that your weapon was made by the lowest bidder.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
What are you?
Are you camping?
Who is this?
Okay, but we know that Emu can bleed now.
We know that God can bleed.
He's not truly a God!
He can bleed!
We know.
Okay, never mind.
Except for...
Well, to be fair, he didn't die to Emu.
Emu still has 14 kills.
If he bleeds, he can die.
So fair.
Wait, another person left?!
Okay, okay.
All I'm saying, guys.
Guys, guys.
Jam's, Jam's, Jam's.
You just joined in?
You just...
Jam's, why don't you like wait a sec?
You leave right now?
Wait like 10 seconds?
Jam's, Jam's.
I'm saying.
You leave right now.
And then you join back 10 seconds later.
Jam's.
That's all I'm saying, Jam's.
Jam's, come on.
It's so funny.
You need...
Wait!
What?!
Let me, let me!
No!
I can't even play on the other team if I want to!
I can't even!
I can't!
No!
Okay.
It's okay.
Nobody join back.
There's no way Emu can kill us all.
Now, now...
Now we can win.
Now it's a 5v3.
It worked.
It worked, guys.
It worked, everybody.
They fell for it.
What?
They fell for it now!
It's a 5v3!
They fucking fell for it!
Nerds.
Wait, how did he die?
Wait, how the fuck did he die?
Is he in there?
They fell for it!
Oh my god!
Finally!
We did it, guys!
We did it!
We fucking did it, guys!
They thought I wanted to be on the enemy team.
But I just wanted to make it a 5v3.
It was planned all along.
This is totally...
You literally have a guy that has 14 plus kills.
This is as fair as it gets.
They need chess.
They fell... I can't believe they fell for it.
Oh, shit!
No!
He's over here!
5v3, I got you.
Jams, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait!
Why is my team a 2v4?
Why is my team 4?
Who left?
No!
I can't believe it.
Now we're 4!
And they have 5!
Jams, do you want to be on the winning team, Jams?
Jams, come on!
Join me.
We have a spot for you, Jams.
Jams, get over here!
Jams, come on!
Get over here, Jams!
It will be so fun, Jams!
Jams, come on!
Now you can be on this team!
Yeah, Jams!
Look!
You get to be on this team!
Look at that!
Look!
See?
Now Jams is on my team!
Now you get to be on my team!
Is that what you guys wanted?
Whoa!
Holy shit!
Please be nice to me.
Guys, if you're a real Dragoon, you let me have one more kill.
Guys, if you're a real Dragoon, you let me have one more kill so I can have more kills than everybody.
So I can be Top Fragger.
Guys.
You let me be Top Fragger.
Guys!
Guys, I thought you wanted me to be Top Fragger.
I need to know my corners.
He's over here.
Bow chicka bow wow.
Guys, he's over here.
Mr. Chucky!
He's to your right.
He's to your left.
Behind you!
Oh shit!
It was worth it.
It was so worth it.
I think that was 100% worth it, guys.
It was so...
...training.
Bro, I think they're just killing every drone they see.
He actually was, but...
...I didn't kill him.
Look, it's not my fault.
He didn't listen to my calls.
I gave him perfectly good callouts, chat.
I gave him good callouts.
It's not my fault he didn't listen to it.
I can't believe that.
That is on him, sir.
If he doesn't want to listen to my calls, then he deserved to get killed in there.
Really?
Yeah, I know that was the enemy team.
I knew it was.
I knew it was the enemy team.
Oh, man.
He's right there!
No, there!
It's like that one guy that was like, to your left!
And then he was to my right.
It was like that one guy.
That one fucker.
I'll never forget him.
To your left!
Honestly, my favorite moment today was the guy that was like, leave me alone.
That's my favorite moment today.
Leave me alone.
He just doesn't like getting...
Whoa!
Okay, that was a good shot.
That was a really good shot, actually.
He bleeds again!
Oh my god!
He bleeds yet again!
Thank you for the 10 gifted chips!
Thank you!
Thank you, Paul!
Okay.
We're fine.
Okay, this way.
I thought it was a dead end.
I don't know why I thought...
This way would lead anywhere.
Okay.
Oh!
Woo!
Oh, I see them.
What?
He saw me?
I didn't even see him!
What the fuck did I get shot?
Oh, it's over here.
Behind you!
To your right!
To your left!
Okay.
I like this game.
I really...
You're too good at this.
It's not my fault they listened to me.
You know they didn't have to listen to me.
It's their fault that they listen.
Where is.
Where are you?
I know you're somewhere in here.
He has to be like camping somewhere.
I don't see him in the hallways.
Guys, I'm trying very hard not to crash into anything right now.
I don't know if that's noticeable.
After crashing into so many corners, I'm trying so hard not to crash anywhere.
Wait, I heard gunshots this direction.
Behind you!
To your left!
To your right, to your right.
To your left, to your left.
In the hallways, in the hallways behind you!
Two, two, two.
Behind you right now!
Right there!
Behind!
In front of you, in front of you, in front of you!
Behind you, behind you!
No!
Take it back now, y'all.
We do a little bit of trolling.
Oh my god, no!
We got the kill there.
I'm gonna miss fuck with my teammate.
Behind you!
He doesn't trust me!
He's like, hey listen!
A bit of tomfoolery.
A bit of tomfoolery here.
Behind you!
This guy doesn't listen!
He does!
In front of you!
Behind!
He's flanking!
Look, if you don't listen to me, you're gonna die.
He's literally flanking right now.
Right behind you.
He's just running!
He's just running away!
What is he doing?
He's flanking!
They learn!
Get out of my head!
They're learning.
They're learning now, guys.
They're learning, guys.
He's flanking!
Same exact place, bro!
Same exact...
She's in their head!
They stopped listening to me.
Oh my god.
Wait, we did it!
I told you he was behind you!
I...
I did say behind you.
I did say it!
I did say it, guys.
Get out of my head!
This is worse than dead space.
It's not my fault.
I didn't say behind you.
I gave good intel.
The clock is right!
Right now!
The clock is right twice a day.
Exactly!
Yeah.
Alright.
It's time to try!
This game needs a drone racing.
No we...
Okay, what all I need all we need is one shot.
Wait was that teammate?
Oops.
Oopsie.
Oopsie, that was a teammate.
My bad.
Oh, I almost shot Allen.
Hey, I got the kill!
I got it back!
Guys, I got back the kill!
It's okay.
Equivalent exchange.
I got a kill.
Guys, it's okay.
I got the kill.
We got a kill back chat.
No, we did our part.
Justice for James.
Guys, I took a life and I gave a life.
There you go, equivalent exchange.
Equivalent exchange chat!
Okay.
How many people died?
I wish it tells you like who's dead and who's alive.
I wish it tells you that.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, I used...
It's a life gun.
Oh, last guy.
Okay.
Woah!
Guys, they knew my plan.
I was gonna lead somebody over to him.
I was gonna...
How did they know?
I was gonna lead somebody to him.
No!
They ruined my plan!
How did they know?
How did they know it was gonna take their life?
They just wised up to me.
I can't believe it!
The fucking drone.
The drone flashlight.
The plan was to find the enemy team and be like, follow me!
And then take him to this... to this... to their last teammate.
There's such a nuisance.
I love it.
Emu, what happened?
You fell off, bro.
Emu, what happened to you?
Wait, we have another?
Wait, we have two players still alive?
Oh shit.
I didn't realize... sorry, I didn't realize you were alive.
Emu, what happened?
Emu!
You used to be a god!
What happened to you?
People used to worship you.
People used to be afraid of you.
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You know, there's a term for having too much...
Whoa!
Liam, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Liam!
Ever since we found out you could bleed, it's all downhill.
You peaked ten rounds ago.
Liam!
Or, Emu!
Hey, what are they doing?
Why are they just both there?
They're just like, maybe he's in that corner.
Just run around!
What's the worst that could happen?
Yeah, they lost their fear.
Ever since we found out.
Beat him!
Wait, there's... oh shit!
What the fuck?
Did we win?
Wait, he wins the point?
Oh my god, it's Emu.
How did they win the point?
I'm running in.
This is it.
They won't expect me.
They won't expect me at all.
I'm gonna run in.
What are they gonna do?
Shoot me back?
Not if I... oh.
Guys.
They shot me back, guys.
They...
Yes.
They... they shot me back, guys.
Who would've thought they could do that?
Hey, I know where they are.
Follow me.
Oh.
Guys, he didn't wanna follow me.
Two bears.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoa, real life looks so... real.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't understand.
Why did they wanna follow me?
I could've led them.
They had enough.
He didn't...
They didn't wanna win.
It's like...
I don't know why they think that I was gonna lead them to their deaths or something.
I don't know where they got that impression.
Cried a little too much.
You're so ungrateful.
I can't believe it.
How can you be so ungrateful?
Trust issues.
Oh my god.
Clutch or kick.
Clutch or kick!
Whoa.
Wait, how many people are still alive?
Okay.
One... one guy.
Just him.
Whoa!
It doesn't even matter if they're teammates.
He fucking was like, no.
That was like our own teammates' drone.
We have one guy that literally has 20 kills.
He's a...
We only discovered that he's not invincible just like five rounds ago.
It's been no fun allowed.
Bro is paranoid as hell now.
I don't think he realized I'm already dead.
I don't think he...
He thinks every drone is me.
He doesn't know.
Oh, but he won't shoot the red drones?
Oh, okay.
Never mind.
He got baited.
He got baited so hard.
Oh my God.
Holy shit.
Guy got baited.
Yeah!
175 rank points!
Let's go!
Alright.
That was really fun.
I'm gonna call it here.
Holy shit.
I didn't expect to play.
I didn't think I was gonna play this game for three hours.
Because when I played the first game, I was like, ooh, I don't know.
This feels like a quick, like, two hours.
And then...
And then maybe we're done.
But then, like, I don't know.
I got actually...
I started enjoying it more and more the more I learned the game.
And then, like, learned how, like, that you can, like, troll people as drones and stuff.
And so it got, like, more and more...
It definitely got more fun as we played.
So, I'm glad that, like...
I got that, like, I...
And I improved a lot, too!
I improved a lot playing the game.
I think I trolled a bit too much at the end, though.
I decided...
I started trolling too much at the end.
Oh, Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rest in peace, my refunds.
GG's, doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah!
I think it's for those who actually enjoy tactical shooters.
Because it is...
It is fun for a tactical shooter.
And, like, you know, I'm not a tactical shooter type of person.
But I did enjoy myself.
Especially, like, just messing around with the drones and stuff.
I think it's, like, fun in a way where...
When you're playing with friends type deal.
Definitely, like, when you're playing with friends and stuff.
But, yeah!
Anyway...
I'm tired.
Sorry for no post-chatting.
There's so much work to do behind the scenes.
But we'll have chatting stream...
We'll have post-stream chats again soon.
We just have a lot of stuff to do behind the scenes.
Almost every day.
So, I have to cut it short here, guys.
But I hope you had fun watching.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Poster check.
Get up and walk...
Get up and move around.
Sorry, I was like, whoa.
Walk.
Get up and move around.
Get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me...
Head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.